welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and it's nice to
see you too see you
Ice Ice Baby Batman is back in a big bad
way and the Caped Crusader is making
clickbait comic book websites richer
than Bruce Wayne there's been a whole
host of reports on how many versions of
Batman is going to be coming out and
throughout this video we'll be breaking
down all of the news you need to know on
whether we think they're true or not
now if you haven't subscribed them make
sure you do otherwise I'll block you and
please drop a thumbs up if you enjoy the
breakdown without the way thank you so
much for clicking this let's get into
our report of all this week's Batman
news okay so since Michael Keaton was
reported as being in talks with Warner
Brothers to take over the role of Ben
Affleck inevitably other things have
started to surface in regards to what
his version of the character will be up
to it was said that Keaton's Batman was
going to be a Nick Fury like men to
figure that popped in and out of
projects across the DCU giving guidance
gadgets and also punching people in the
face with Keaton being an older actor
many started theorized that he would
become a Bruce Wayne and Batman Beyond
type figure and this quickly got a lot
of fans excited over the possibility of
Terry McGinnis appearing in the DC EU -
well it looks like things are actually
in the works with a lot of comic-book
websites dropping reports and there
being a movie in development featuring
Batman Beyond at Warner Brothers super
duper pooper-scooper Daniel RPK put out
a post last week that said Batman Beyond
is currently being worked on and then
comic book coma just put out a huge
article discussing it now as always take
this with a pinch of salt as it doesn't
come from trades and it's instead from a
scooper with inside sources that can't
be named but saying that actually do you
think that this rumor makes a lot of
sense and that's why there's a ton of
weight that comes with it now to me this
kind of thing rests on the caveat that
the Keaton talks are true as I think
that if you don't have him and you can't
really make an older Bruce Wayne which
means you then can't have Batman Beyond
and so on and so forth however if they
are true then it definitely fits in
with the overall at WB vision at the
moment and I think it makes a lot of
sense as we know Pattinson z' film will
most likely be in a standalone universe
similar to the Joker and thus the DC EU
needs its own Batman Keaton is probably
too old at this point to be believably
taking down mr. freeze and his ice puns
so he's likely been given the cold
shoulder in favor of a young
up-and-comer
that's far cooler than he is it's the
best of both worlds and for someone
that's wanted to see Batman Beyond on
the big screen for yes now I definitely
think it makes sense to do it now when
we have an older Batman in place now
coupled with the Keaton rumors are ones
that Michelle Pfeiffer will be coming
back if he does - if you checked out
crisis on Infinite Earths and you may
remember that there was an easter egg in
that in which we saw the 89 Batman
universe and Robert wall wall was
reading a clickbait newspaper that said
Bruce had married Selena and due to ezra
showing up and talking to grant gustin's
flash the DC EU and this world could all
be linked so once more we have news
hanging on the caveat that if Keaton
comes back then we could be getting
Batman Beyond and Michelle Pfeiffer
breaking out the old cat suit for the
boys or girls we don't discriminate now
I hope Keaton does do it especially if
they're connecting everything together
like the arrowverse and flash movie
which is what he's meant to be debuting
in I'd really love to see Keaton back in
the cave and hopefully Ezra goes around
and asks them nicely to come back no no
no Ezra no stop you you killing her I'm
speaking of Keaton you may have also
seen rumors that stem from
super-duper-duper pooper-scooper Jeremy
Conrad that if talks fall through with
Keaton that Christian Bale will be asked
to take over the reins
Conrad also said that WB had not
approached Ben Affleck and that they
decided to go in another direction which
does add more weight to our thinking
that a flick won't be back because yeah
why would he if they're casting other
actors in the role surely you would just
use Affleck if you were going to do any
of that stuff and you wouldn't need to
recast yeah I still don't get how these
rumors pick up so much steam anyway I've
noticed a lot of sites running with the
Bale story just for the sake of running
with it because it's been a slow news
and they need people to visit their site
but no bail is not in talks
it's just that WB are thinking of
approaching him a lot of sites have sort
of embellished on what Conrad initially
actually said and put words in his mouth
saying that bail will definitely be back
if Keaton's not luckily we here at the
channel can actually read and Conrad's
exact words on the post where I've
learned that if the Keating talks fall
through and he doesn't come back WB will
attempt to get Christian Bale to return
again as an older Batman from a
different universe who will take on the
mentor role in the DCE you following
flashpoint soft reboot of course that
raises the question about whether or not
bail would even want to come back
without Nolan involved but the idea that
WB would go to bail before Affleck shows
that they're respecting his newfound
happiness with putting the Batman role
behind him one could only hope that
bands do his will so yeah at no point
does he say that bail isn't talks I
doubt that he would come back since the
actor has said multiple multiple
multiple times that he won't be bailed
basically went through the same thing as
batfleck where he was asked numerous
times if he would come back and he said
no this was around the time of BVS being
developed before Ben was cast in the
role and he was asked absolutely none
stop back then and you could tell the
guy was sick of being asked it even got
to the point that a fan theory developed
which said that Deathstroke was actually
masquerading as Batman in Batman V
Superman and that Bale would be coming
back further down the line if you're old
enough to remember that then this is
probably why you've seen the same thing
happening with batfleck and now that
this sort of thing always happens around
the time of a recast the bail thing is
so bad that even the sites running this
story are pretty much telling you that
this isn't happening and is a lot of
crap
and if you look at Conrad's original
post and no point does he say it's true
so I can't see it happening at all if it
does I'll eat my bat and yes it's still
far too soon to be making jokes like
that now before we get into the rest of
the video I just want to let you know
we're giving away a free copy of the MCU
infinity saga box set to one random
subscriber all you have to do to be in
with a chance of winning is like the
video subscribe to the channel
leave your thoughts on the updates in
the comment section below the winners
gonna be chosen at random on the 15th of
July in the cell be shipped out from
then to ever get surprised it's the best
of luck to everyone who takes part ok
and finally is the news that cetana
is currently in development a Warner
Bros now we kinda touched on this before
and did a whole segment on it in our
last video but if you go to the DC
fandom mobile website you can submit
your questions to panels and upcoming
projects amongst the likes of Aquaman
Shazam the Snyder cut and more were two
secret movies and it looks like we might
know at least one of them will be cetana
again this comes from super-duper
Trouper bloody pooper scooper Jeremy
Conrad who says that WP has finally
begun development on a movie featuring
cetana
and I'm told this will be separate from
the Justice League project bad robot is
working on it also sounds like other
characters who have been members of
Justice League dark might also head to
the big screen but that's much further
out
I know Jeremy Conrad doesn't sound that
cool in real life yeah but I'm I'm doing
you a favor there mate yeah so make sure
you thumbs it up now this has a lot of
contention to it with Grace Randolph
staying at the film project was two
years ago and that cetana will actually
just be appearing in the HBO Mac show so
bit back and forth over what's true and
what isn't but it was definitely
reported by deadline two years ago that
cetana was in the works but whether this
has been revitalized or not we don't
know
so either Jeremy is the one telling the
truth or grace is a bloody disgrace
sorry about that grace if you're
watching this yeah I don't know what's
true and what isn't but personally I
would lean more towards the Turner just
being in with the group in Justice
League dark as it doesn't make sense to
do a solo movie that isn't associated
with with them but I suppose we are
getting 25 batman movies so if it is
true then that's probably going to be
the secret movie and if it's not then
it's not gonna be the secret movie yeah
we're working it all out here now of
course with news on this everyone has
been doing their fan casting which is
ranged from anna de armas to isaac
Gonzalez Tom Holland Robert Downey jr.
and a lot more
that's a joke by the way because those
two always get fan casted and everything
and I'm talking about the first two
obviously now I actually think that
Gonzalez know a bit of a Xuan would be
great in the role she was brilliant in
bloodshot and she left my eyes bloodshot
from all the Wang wandering I was doing
about her being in a DC movie she's
proved she can be part of a big-budget
movie and fit in with the best of them
so I definitely think that out of all of
the ones I've seen so far she seems the
best she also wears a hat in a photo so
all the people that make fan art they've
had half their job done for them I might
even drop that fall in the thumbnail to
trick people into watching this and
obviously it worked because you're here
okay so that's everything to get you up
to date I'm actually taking a week off
this week so if there's any big Batman
use probably won't be around to cover it
until about the 12th of July at the
earliest I've got a couple of videos
lined up to keep the channel taking over
until then but they aren't anything
breaking news wise so if the Batmobile
shows up to your house and I don't talk
about it then you know why I know no one
else watches these videos other than me
and you so we should be okay just make
sure you don't tell anyone about the
Batmobile news otherwise I'll block you
and also hit the thumbs up button on the
way out yeah now if you missed our last
DC breakdown on the right Fisher drama
the secret DC movies are more than make
sure you check it out after this if you
want to support the channel and get to
see content early and please consider
clicking the join button you can also
come chat to us on our discord server
link below or at heavy spoilers on
Twitter thanks for making it until the
end of the video you've been the best
I've been definition and I'll see you
next time take care peace let's ice -
see you - see you ice
you